very good evening to you you're watching
the press preview first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive here
in
our studios in the next half an hour
we'll be seeing what's making the
headlines with the broadcaster and
former mp anna subray and the mail on
sunday commentator dan hodges we'll see
you in just a moment
but first let's take a look at what's on
some of those front pages shall we the
metro reporting that boris johnson's
cabinet secretary
simon case worked in the household of
the duke and duchess of sussex at the
time
it's alleged she bullied members of her
staff claims
which she denies the mirror is leading
with a backlash against the government's
proposal to give health service staff a
one percent pay rise the paper
calls it an insult to nhs workers
sunac under fire as nhs staff offered
one percent pay rise it's also the lead
for the guardian
though the times reports that
wednesday's budget has found favor with
some
as a yougov poll revealing the
conservative now conservatives now have
a 13-point lead
over labor the telegraph is reporting on
the eu countries that are now making the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine available to
the over 65s after
initially questioning its efficacy and
in the yorkshire post
she sunax said to be facing a backlash
from northern leaders after his own
north yorkshire constituencies given
more so-called leveling up funding
than others the financial times has a
story concerning the
steel company gfg alliance
and the prime minister is worried that
the final bill for renovations of his
and fiance carrie simmons downing street
flat could top 200 000 pounds that's
according to a source
that the mail has spoken to
okay well as i was saying earlier we're
joined tonight by anna subri
and dan hodges so let's take a look at
the story that is in so many of the
papers shall we this
uh pay freeze is being recommended by
the government and it's not going to
wash very well
with the unions but what about the
public anna subari
i think the public will be horrified by
this i think
that there's a recognition that our nhs
workers have gone way
beyond what anybody could have expected
of them
and the reality is is i mean i actually
think our nhs is
not just under terrible stress and
strain now and our work the workers
are absolutely exhausted but they are
that we are going in effect to need some
sort of
nhs recovery plan but
it's it's only in two of the papers and
it's the leaders you've identified
in the mirror and it's also the lead in
the guardian
it's not as far as i can see in or some
of the babies don't mention it at all
and i think that's quite deliberate
because i think that the public
will expect our nhs workers to get a lot
more
one percent it's just not good enough
yeah it's interesting isn't it and it's
kind of like it's slipped out as well
you know it's it's it there's a feeling
that it's been
sneaked out and that goes down really
badly
and dan hodges the royal college of
nursing have reacted calling this
pitiful and bitterly disappointing they
want to see a twelve and a half percent
increase
they say that one percent uh represents
three pounds fifty a week
extra for an experienced nurse now after
what those nurses have done for all of
us this year
bit of pill to swallow isn't it
it is but i think it's uh it's a
reflection of
of the broader issues that were thrown
up by the budget yesterday obviously
these are very bad headlines
um for rishi sunak we also saw some
some bad headlines yesterday in relation
to tax rises
i think we're going to see some bad
headlines moving forward in relation to
public spending cuts we're going to see
some bad headlines in relation to the
size
of the public debt and we're going to
see some bad headlines moving forward in
relation to the the quite anemic growth
that is predicted
once we've had the sort of post-coverage
v-shaped recovery
i think that i think i agree with anna i
think there will be a a public reaction
i'm not entirely sure
it will be quite as bad as she's been
setting out i mean we have to say there
is a
um an opinion poll that's been that has
been published this evening which shows
quite significant public support for the
budget
but i i do think with these things it
tends to take a bit of time but
before the full effects come through but
but but moving away
from the headline as i say the reality
is
that that this is a reflection of the
absolutely dire situation
that the public finances and the british
economy
is facing and we're all facing as we all
try to deal with the impact of the coded
recession and the kodi downturn
and i think moving forward
i think the the rishi sunak and the
government while they may be getting
some plaudits in the short term for the
budget
but obviously this isn't the best
example of it i do
think it as i say it underlines
fundament
much more fundamental issues that are
going to cause real political problems
for both rishi sunak and boris johnson
as we move forward i mean i can see you
nodding there and i mean the institute
for fiscal studies today
saying that the budget really
represented four billion pounds in
spending cuts and whatever way you look
at it it's going to represent some real
pain isn't it
yes um and i agree obviously i
absolutely agree with dan's take on
the public reaction to the budget but
actually i think that there's a good
argument that people people aren't daft
they know that the furlough scheme has
cost the public purse an extraordinary
amount of money they know that the
vaccines have cost an extraordinary
amount of money
the the rather failed test and trace and
so on and so forth
they know it's got to be paid for so i
think they will take
effectively the tax rises that they will
have had
um and i think they will take to some
extent
cut some form of cuts in some areas of
public spending
but not to have mentioned in that budget
anything about the nhs
and now we know why and not to tackle
social care
when we know that these these things
have been heightened so much
during the covet crisis i think the
public
will will be genuinely cross and it will
be interesting to see as dan rightly
identifies
how the opinion polls now
wind out as some of this comes home but
i think the people realize
tough things have to be done but not to
the nhs and its magnificent works
okay let's turn our attention to the
daily telegraph dan uh meghan markle or
i should say that the duchess
of sussex featuring on the front there
their take
is that the sussexes haven't been
informed of this unprecedented inquiry
being held
by buckingham palace into those
allegations that she she was a bully
tell us more
well i mean this is all part of the sort
of the much
broader um if you like psycho drama that
is attending
um the sussex is obviously in the lead
up to the great
uh opera winfrey sit down um
that we're all gonna be all well some of
us are waiting with
with baited breath others of us just
can't wait for we've got out of the way
but
let's give give up for a little watch um
but this is if you like one of the more
serious aspects of the psycho drama
which is the allegations
um that she has been involved in in
bullying of her staff
now her and her allies
will say indeed which i think she
explicitly has said
that this is simply just another attempt
by the
the royal family to smear her
others however would say it's it's a
reflection of
the broader issues in relation to her
and
her character i mean i i've got to be
honest i'm saying about this today i
mean i
i really haven't been following the
twists and turns of
of all this but oh dan where have you
been
[Laughter]
it's all anyone's talking about today
but uh but you know look the reality is
they've done this great sit-down
interview
they're inviting us all virtually
insisting we all
we all take a side and i've got to be
honest
i don't think either meghan markle
or or prince harry are going to come out
of this um
quite in the way that they thought they
were going to when they uh when they
decided to give up opera her her
exclusive all those
all those weeks ago although clearly you
know megan must have known
what she was going to be in for having
said herself in her own words that the
firm
were perpetuating falsehoods i mean she
can't have expected that to have gone
unnoticed interesting who else is being
drawn into this though the metro
pointing out that of course simon case
who was private secretary at the time
to the duke and duchess is now cabinet
secretary for boris johnson
prime minister saying that he's got full
confidence in him but
getting sort of sucked into this
so-called psychodrama as well
yes and therefore somehow the prime
minister's drawn into it
i mean it's a nonsense isn't it i mean
i'm sorry but i think there are far more
important things to be on our papers
than this and i mean and the people who
are going to benefit i mean april
winfrey must be just
loving it all this publicity for this
interview
but you know meghan markle has made some
because of course the the clip that was
out today
was pre-recorded obviously and it was
recall
it was the interview was given before
this latest revelation from the palace
which i think they should not be doing
they i don't know why they are engaging
in this i just think it demeans
the royal family and i think the queen
should step in and say right
no more of this if they want to give
interviews to april then
and let them just go on and do that
stuff but what i do hope happens is that
when
in that interview the oprah winfrey
winfrey actually challenges and says
well what are these terrible falsehoods
that they've told about you
what are these terrible things that
they've done to you because just
making these claims without any
substantial
evidence if you like it is not
acceptable